no one owes you anything and if you're
doing a job because you're expecting to
get another job you gotta find what you
like about it I know that's you hear it
all the time
you finally join what you do but the
older to get you realize that's really
the truth because it put me in such a a
mood of I know this and people know what
I can do and just give it to me give it
to me entitlement that it really starts
to weigh you down and it starts to
infiltrate you in negative ways and you
don't enjoy where you're around I
remember Ken Marino it's why he's such a
great guy his wife Erica Yama wrote this
thing really funny digital series called
burning love that Ken was in of so many
funny people were in that and I was
shooting that and I was just in a
terrible mood and like Ken had to bring
me inside like while we're shooting you
know I didn't know disruption during the
set but between takes I was just like
not the greatest of moods and he said
what's up man he's like man I can't I
love you I love this this is so funny
like I just gonna be doing this like web
shows like it was really narrow-minded
ungrateful type of stuff and he heard me
as a friend and he related and Here I am
talking to someone that also hadn't got
his big but Ken's amazing send all this
stuff but also hadn't gotten his break
and you've realized you just end up
sounding like a complete [ __ ] because
you can't see your path you can't see
when is your time and it took me a while
and if I had kept in that kind of mode
well then I don't get Brooklyn nine-nine
and now Brooklyn nine-nine has given me
a gift that is above and beyond I mean I
have a new family I've gone through life
changes several of us have gotten
married several of us have gotten have
had kids including myself if I had like
now [ __ ] it I'm not going in that is not
open to me anymore that's not here and
that's a very humbling place to be when
you're like now I'm getting it this
struggle is real even after you think
you've made the big time not the big
time but like super bad it is super bad
I'm like that movie was huge I'm like up
well here we go it's the only a matter
of time now start getting the calls here
they come they don't come
you know you still have to go in you
suck to do all that stuff so you just
have to keep it in check because no one
owes you anything no one's gonna give
you the money for the movie
no one's gonna write the script for you
no one's going to like create the ideal
part for you you find it you get it or
just follow or if you don't know how to
get it follow the things that are coming
at you that are opening up to you and
maybe that will lead you there I know
there was a there was a lot of that
stuff going on for me about seven years
ago